kaisen il faut prévoir des cd
d'installation pour mac
[Musique]
bon la leçon c'est pas top je vous
emmène chercher une solution avec moi
il fait beau
chaque oeil mais c'est beau je me suis
rendu compte que sur quelques vidéos
zoom au micro qui était pas terrible et
qui donnait un rendu qui était pas hyper
qualitatif je veux y voir chez mon pote
matteo qui tient une boutique de son qui
va pouvoir probablement proposer une
solution qui sera beaucoup plus adéquat
je pense que un micro-cravate safra la
faire le petit micro rod que j'ai
directement sur la caméra c'est pas mal
mais pas en toutes circonstances
[Musique]
comme le vendait sa 35e mais franchement
ça va être dur c'est un budget quoi je
vais essayer avec le cravate et puis
après cool merci la mascotte qui dort la
bombe à théo t'étais pas là mais en tout
cas je te fais un bisou à coeur y était
il vient d'arriver à la terre de son
voilà tout l'intérêt de toujours
vérifier que son bateau c'est bien
connecté là sur la prise derrière j'ai
mal branché mon micro derrière j'ai pas
vérifié
du coup le son est pourri donc m'en
voulez pas pour ce coup mais là c'est
pas terrible je fais demi tour et
toujours moi désolé pas équipés
devraient sortir tous les jours dit
d'orge avec morts en ce moment j'ai
arrêté de dormir ouais c'est clair
sortez ça va c'est pas du whisky la même
couleur mais pas de mon goût
j'ai pas les mêmes effets le thé pur
malt presse qu'il faut monsieur greu il
faut tout simplement un micro qui se
branchent avec un petit jack soit sur un
smartphone site à l'entrée micro ou sur
un appareil photo ou une petite caméra
c'est des micros qui sont alimentés et
c'est très très compact pour les vélo'v
c'est top
l'euro doit c'est ça le vidéo micro il
est bien sûr non c'est ça c'est le vide
et aux mythes pro le vidéo micro et
ouais
après il ya plusieurs modèles dans la
gamme ça tu penses que pour faire tout
ce qui est vidéo enveloppe c'est ce qu'à
mieux carrément mais le petit cravate là
pour l'intérieur c'est pas mal aussi
en fait chaque micro à des directivité
différentes en fonction d'utilisation il
ya plein de solutions possibles on a
aussi qui sont pour chez toi quand tu
veux plutôt faire du broadcast en studio
yes mais là pour du portable c'est
nickel ça peut se brancher sur une
caméra un appareil photo ou sur un
système os mots tels que le tramway
et du coup tu vas pas être déçu du son
ouais ça c'est pas mal ok ça lâche c'est
calme en ce moment j'ai l'impression
on a connu des périodes plus chargé mais
là après les fêtes c'est vrai qu'il ya
un petit peu moins de monde c'est un peu
plus calme c'est plutôt calme
les gens ont la gueule de bois en ce
moment on cherche quoi joue certes il
est passé ça va bientôt tomber
ouais t'es cool merci s est également
excellent toujours aussi sympa matteo
merci maintenant direct sur le bureau je
vais aller essayer ce nouveau micro
cravate et on va voir si le test est
concluant
en tout cas encore un grand merci à
matteo terres de son on s'est vraiment
franchement bien marrer c'est la voiture
de ma femme
il ya plein de trucs bizarres dans sa
voiture ça je crois que c'est pour faire
une perfusion 15,8 c'est un petit peu au
besoin d'un pansement et plein de trucs
dans la bagnole d'une infirmière c'est
incroyable voilà ce que j'ai pris chez
terres de son merci matteo merci les
gars super conseil on va regarder ce
cador
donc là je suis en train d'enregistrer
avec le micro avec le rhode le vidéo
micro que j'utilise tout le temps avec
lequel je dois reconnaître j'ai
quelquefois un son qui me convient pas
le son est un petit peu loin et je pense
qu'on peut faire mieux qu'en terme de
qualité
ça c'est un micro cravate alors qu'elle
que vous en fichez avec ça normalement
le son sera nettement meilleur le micro
cravate
il est alimenté je sais jamais où est le
plus c'est moi là dessus la bonne est
pour éviter d'avoir des dessus c'est
hyper important de mettre une bonne est
sur un micro parce que sinon vous avez
tous les bruits tous les postillons
déclin qui peut devancer la mort là au
moins vous n'êtes pas envers des jeux
comme ça à l'arraché en pull changement
micro
je disais donc là normalement vous
n'entendez rien parce qu'il faut que je
plusse l'interrupteur en off
et alors ce qui est génial avec ça c'est
que je peux me mettre loin loin loin et
normalement vous avez toujours le son
avec la même qualité et ça c'est génial
parce qu'avant avec le micro que j'avais
j'ai été obligé d'être hyper proches
comme ça la limite peut coller presque à
rouler une pelle à les caméras tandis
que là je peux me mettre à distance et
le son est toujours le même et ça c'est
vraiment génial
donc au final le petit micro road c'est
génial pour les plans extérieur
ça me permet effectivement avec la
grande beune est anti vente pas être
endetté
j'ai un son qui est propre ça c'est
nickel par contre pour tous les autres
plans à l'intérieur franchement le micro
cravate
je crois que c'est ce qu'ils aillent
mieux le micro cravate ça reste quand
même la meilleure alternative dans les
locaux fermés comme ça je n'embête pas
le son ne plus prendre je peux bouger le
son reste le même temps disque avec ça
quand je bouge
forcément même si c'est un micro qui
parlait capter un peu dans
l'environnement tour j'aurais jamais la
même qualité de son d'ailleurs si vous
regardez la vidéo d'hier vous le verrez
tout de suite quand je suis dans une
certaine position le son est meilleur
et quand je passe sur une autre position
le son est nettement moins bien je pense
qu'avec le micro cravate
j'aurai toujours la même homogénéité de
son et c'est ça qui est vraiment génial
donc si vous voulez faire un blog que je
vous conseille moi c'est soit d'investir
sur un super micro vous avez posé sur
une caméra vous avez posé sur un boîtier
canon est dans ce sens que vous voulez
mais par contre ça va vous coûter 200
euros pour avoir vraiment le haut de
gamme par exemple de chez rohde et vous
aurez un micro qui sera génial par
contre si vous voulez pas mettre trop
cher vous prenez un petit micro cravate
filaires comme ça ça va vous coûter 35
euros 35 39 euros par contre pour tous
les plans extérieur ça reste pas mal
partager vos conseils et vos astuces en
commentaire dites moi quel micron vous
utilisez il ya probablement des tonnes
de configuration différente et je pense
qu'elle a pour tous les goûts et pour
tous les cas de figure si toi tu fais
des vidéos dix mois qu'est-ce que tu
utilises quel matériel tu as comment tu
l'utilisent dans quels cas et au final
est ce que tu en es satisfait si ces
quelques conseils non plus inscris-toi
la chaîne mais un petit pouce vers le
haut et partage
merci et à demain
[Musique]